So this book a blueprint,
the evolutionary origins of a good society.
When did you start this?
About nine or 10 years ago.
Uh,
and I,
at the time in my lab we were doing research on friendship.
We were doing research on,
on why people have friends.
It's actually,
it's not,
it's not difficult to provide an account for why we have sex with each other.
Uh,
many animals,
most animals are,
well,
I don't know if it's most,
but uh,
animals either reproduce sexually or asexually and most animals,
I'm trying to remember now what the relative proportions anyway,
mama say most,
most animals reproduce sexually and it's not hard to provide an account for how,
um,
for why we,
why sex originated,
why we reproduce sexually.
It's not hard to provide an account for why we are choosy in our mates or why
we,
uh,
are careful in who we have sex with.
But human beings don't just mate with each other.
We befriend each other.
We form longterm non reproductive unions to other individuals to whom we're not
related.
Why?
That's very rare in the animal kingdom.
Very few creatures do this.
We do it.
Certain other primates,
elephants,
certain whales.
And that's mostly it.
So the question is why.
So I became very interested in my lab and try and understand the deep origins of
friendship.
Why would natural selection have equipped us with this capacity?
And that set the stage then for an exploring all kinds of other things in our
lives.
Like why we love each other.
For example,
why do we,
when we have a sex with a person,
we tend to become attached to them.
We develop emotional sentiment about them.
That's not an essential to having sex yet.
We do that.
And then I became interested in other kinds of good things like not into just
love and friendship,
but cooperation and teaching.
Teaching is another crazy thing.
We take it for granted that we teach each other.
But think about this.
Most animals are able to learn.
So a little fish in the ocean learns that if it swims to the light,
it finds more food there.
So the fish then learns to,
to,
to be tropic,
to move towards the light.
Uh,
and that's individual learning.
Some animals develop what's called social learning.
Social learning is really efficient.
So if I put my hand in the fire,
I learned that I burned myself.
I pull my hand out,
I've learned something,
I paid a price and I learned something.
I could observe you putting your hand in the fire,
you pay all the price.
But I gained most of the knowledge.
It's almost as good.
I learned,
oh people,
you shouldn't put your hand in the fire,
saw the job that is end of the fire.
So social learning is super efficient learning from others,
but we take it to an even further level.
We don't just passively observe other,
other animals of our own species and learn from them.
We teach each other.
That is very rare in the animal kingdom where one animal sets out to teach and
other animals something.
So the book is,
uh,
is,
is about the evolutionary origins of a good society.
It's also a kind of a response to kind of push back to a,
a long tradition in the sciences of attention to the bad parts of our nature.
You know,
a scientist in my view have for too long been looking at the origins of,
of murder and tribalism and selfishness and a mendacity.
Um,
but,
but I think the bright side has been denied the attention it deserves because we
have also evolved to love and to befriend each other and to be kind to each
other and to cooperate and to teach each other and all these good things.
And I'll shut up and uh,
please don't know.
And uh,
and here's the thing.
Here's this sort of one way to think about this.
This must have been the case that the benefits of a connected life outweighed
the costs.
We would not be living socially if my exposure to you harmed me on net.
In other words,
if I came near you and you were violent to me,
you killed me,
or you gave me misinformation,
you told me lies about the world than my connection to you would ultimately harm
me.
That I should be better off living as an isolated animal.
So animals that come together to live socially there,
the benefits of that must outweigh the costs.
My living us living as a group,
so all this attention to the ways in which our interactions are bad,
that we kill each other,
that we steal from each other,
that we lie to each other,
that we have tribalism and all of these traits which we do every century is
replete with horrors.
I'm not like Pangloss like I don't think like,
you know,
Pollyanna like,
oh,
everything's great.
That's not me.
But what is me is a kind of optimistic focus on the good parts of our,
of human nature and the recognition that those good parts must in toto
overwhelmed the bad parts.
Well they certainly have to,
there's so many human beings.
I mean it's obvious that this is working.
Yes.
I mean we propagated where everywhere on every single patch of land that's
occupiable.
In fact you're,
you're exactly right.
The argument,
and that's discussed in the book,
the way we have achieved the kind of social conquest of the earth,
the way our species is,
is as spread out to occupy every niche,
which is also very rare.
Most animals live in one,
you know,
grizzlies living in this part of the world.
They don't live in Amazonia.
And,
uh,
you know,
polar bears live in this part of the world take,
don't live in,
in,
uh,
Arizona,
et cetera.
So,
so,
uh,
but our species lives everywhere.
And the way we have come to be able to do that is by the capacity to have
culture,
to teach and learn from each other,
to accumulate knowledge.
So in the book I talk about lots of this famous set of stories called the last
European explorer files about how European explorers are lost.
They lose their supplies,
they wind up dying.
And um,
but they're in an environment in which other people thrive and survive because
they have learned to how to live there.
So we've spread out around the world.
And then though there's a chapter in the book at the beginning about shipwrecks.
So,
so I have this,
should I go on chap?
Yeah.
So I have this,
uh,
is,
I have this,
uh,
so,
so what I'd like to do is,
what I try to set out to do in the beginning of the book is I say,
look,
it's clear that our genes shaped the structure and function of our bodies.
It is increasingly clear that our genes also straight shape the structure and
function of our minds,
our behaviors,
whether you are risk averse,
uh,
how intelligent you are,
whether you have wanderlust,
uh,
these properties are properties that depend in part on your genes.
But it's also clear to me,
and that's what the book argues,
is that our genes shape not just the structure and function of our bodies,
not just the structure and function of our minds,
but also the structure and function of our societies.
And to really prove that what we would need is something known as the forbidden
experiment.
And the forbidden experiment is an experiment in which we took a group of babies
who had never been taught anything,
who are a cultural,
had no culture and stranded them on an island and left them on their own to see
what kind of society they would make when they grew up.
You know,
how would they organize themselves socially?
Is there kind of an innate society that human beings are,
are pre wired to make in an essence.
Now obviously that's unethical and cruel,
but actually monarchs for thousands of years have contemplated this experiment.
So Heraclitus writes in about how one of the ancient Egyptian Pharaohs wanted to
know what kind of language would,
what was a natural language we had in us that we would speak if we were not
taught a language.
So this pharaoh,
it has said took two babies and gave them to a mute shepard to raise to see how
did the children's speak when they grew up.
And uh,
and,
and uh,
Emperor Akbar attempted this,
there was a couple of European kings that attempted this.
Obviously we can't actually do this.
So what I do in the book is I look at a series of other approximations of that.
And one chapter is devoted to looking at shipwrecks groups of men typically,
but sometimes men and women who,
between 1500 and 1900,
there were 9,000 shipwrecks.
Many more thousands of ships were lost at sea.
And in 20 of those cases,
we found 20 cases where,
uh,
at least 19 people were stranded for at least two months.
And,
uh,
you know,
here's a,
there's a,
a kind of,
um,
here's a map of the,
uh,
here's one crew I can tell you about it,
but here's a map of the,
of the shipwrecks.
Like these are the,
Oh wow.
The all over the world where they occurred and,
uh,
when they occurred and how many people there were.
And,
uh,
and so then I,
I,
uh,
I got all the original accounts from the sailors,
from the people on the wrecks.
And all contemporary archeological excavations of those wrecks were where they
had been excavated.
And,
um,
and try to understand what kind of society these isolated crews actually wind up
making.
And there was some amazing stories that were,
uh,
that I found in there.
So they stayed for at least two months.
How many of them actually established a real civilization?
How many of stuck forever?
No,
no one was stuck forever.
Most of those crews were eventually,
in fact,
all of those crews had at least one survivor because if they had all died,
uh,
then I wouldn't be able to know about them.
But there's a one famous case in which these sailors were stranded in near
Australia,
I think somewhere in the Pacific.
And they managed to catch a big petrol,
one of those huge birds that,
you know,
like the condor and uh,
and they,
they,
they put a little note in a little tiny bottle and they tied it to its feet.
And this petro flew thousands of miles and landed in Australia and was found
with a note indicating where the ice stranded sailors were.
And to ship was sent to go find the men and it got there,
but they had all died.
They were all gone.
So they use this,
this,
uh,
this bird.
So the bird,
well,
no,
they didn't eat the bird.
They put shit up.
No.
I think if you had that choice,
you would communicate rather than eat Joe.
I think.
Yes.
Yeah.
For a little bit.
Well,
until the very expert.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
But they starve to death then we don't know.
Nobody knows.
But the point is that we have to have it for me to be able to describe what
happened.
We needed at least one survivor.
And often there were many cases where everyone survived.
I mean,
there was one pair of cases that I was amazing to me in 1846 in south Auckland
islands,
just north of Antarctica,
south of New Zealand.
Uh,
the,
uh,
the Grafton was wrecked on the southern part of the island.
I can't remember how big the island was.
I,
it's in the book,
I may be,
let's say 90 miles long or something,
or 20 miles long.
And these 20 miles long on the southern part of the island,
uh,
five men are wrecked in the Grafton.
And,
uh,
on the northern part of the island,
the Invercote rex 19 men are wrecked on the INVICO.
Uh,
all the Grafton cruise survives.
The,
and both P,
both crews were on the island at the same time.
They never encountered each other.
They're struggling for survival.
It's like an,
like an experiment.
Like who's going to win?
I'm tempted to say fear factor.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
and,
and the question is who's going to survive and how and why?
Everyone on the graft and crew survives,
and 16 of the 19 men on the,
uh,
on the Invercote crew die.
There's also cannibalism in that crew.
So it's a,
it's a very,
it's a very different outcome for various reasons.
So,
anyway,
so the point is that in the book,
I start with a series of stories about how people come together to make,
attempt to make new civilizations.
I use the example of unintentional communities with,
uh,
with shipwrecks.
I have,
I looked at it,
intentional communities like communes and um,
and a kibbutz in Israel and a 1970s communes in the United States,
a 19th century communes in the United States.
Actually going back to Roman times.
There've always been groups of people who've said,
society's fucked up.
I'm going to go and we're going to make it again.
You know,
we're going to start a fresh.
Um,
I look at settlements in Antarctica of a scientist's,
I look at the pit Karen,
you know,
the mutiny on the bounty.
I look at the Shackleton expedition.
Many,
many cases of stranded,
isolated groups of people trying to make a new social order.
And then I also use data from,
um,
experiments we do in my lab.
We have the software where tens of thousands of people have come and played
these games.
We can create these temporary artificial societies of real people where people
come and spend an hour or two and we would as godlike way can engineer the
society.
We can have a lot of inequality or little inequality or various other features.
And then we can observe what happens.
And I look at all of that data,
all those stories,
and say,
look,
there is a deep and fundamental way that no matter what human beings,
uh,
make a society their underlying fundamental principles about society,
which are as innate as the fact that you have two kidneys.
You know,
most people,
almost everyone or your pancreas makes insulin,
but they're very different all throughout the world,
right?
I mean there's totalitarian society.
No,
no.
So here's the point.
No,
yeah.
So here's what,
here's the argument.
You look around the world and the way,
the example I give is that yes,
there's huge cultural variation around the world.
Just like you said,
to tell turn societies.
There's people have different foods and they have different ways of dressing and
there's enormous cultural variation.
And it's marvelous and interesting and obvious to anybody.
But I think we're missing the forest from the trees.
To me,
this is like you and I are sitting on a plane and we look it up a hill that's
300 feet and 900 feet.
And we say those are very different hills.
But actually if we took a step back,
we would see that we're on,
we were on a plateau and one was a mountain that was 10,300 feet,
and another was a mountain that was 10,900 feet.
And actually there,
there are these much more deep and fundamental plate tectonic forces that are
creating these two mountains that are very similar.
But we are just focused on the superficial top.
So the argument in the book is that everywhere in the world,
people have friendship.
People love their partners,
people cooperate,
people teach each other.
These are fundamental common principals shared by everyone,
even though there's also a lot of variation.